conservatives from all over the country
are in suburban Washington tonight for
their annual conference known as CPAC
correspondent Doug mackelway is live
tonight in National Harbor Maryland to
tell us the big topic is what the
Democrats are doing to each other at a
time of historically low unemployment
and economic expansion conservatives see
advantage in the leftward lurch of the
Democratic Party
the latest example the green New Deal to
pay for the Green Deal all you need to
do is just keep borrowing and borrowing
barri this is such a naive thought in
the world of debt that I can't even
respond to it
the Left tilt is a target-rich
environment say conservatives from the
alleged hoaxes of Jesse small at the
Covington kids the embrace of late term
abortions the scandals in Virginia
Democratic politics to the recent
discovery of a 1980s Bernie Sanders
quote about the goodness of Food lines
were nice Anders that was talking about
it's good to be in line to wait for food
we've got to get to a point where we
celebrate capitalism and that is the
other theme of CPAC this year three
percent growth as far as the eye can see
it's the hottest economy of the world
and I'll let the ankle-biters
just bite our ankles confronting those
successes is a sober demographic reality
polls suggesting Millennials are
embracing socialism and a far left
agenda this is now a voting issue across
the country the green generation has
risen up that while the GOP remains
older and largely white CPAC organizers
are intent on changing that this
breakout session with young minorities
many facing daunting peer pressure is
one example do you have people come up
to you and tell you that you hate
yourself and you're an Uncle Tom but
Joel Patrick is preaching conservatism
to his quarter million Instagram
followers while hayden williams invited
to CPAC after he was punched out for
being a conservative at UC Berkeley kept
his camera rolling I'm sure probably 10
million people have seen it Republicans
have been late in embracing social media
but they are doing it now fully
cognizant that it is the way to reach a
new generation of voters
right Doug mackelway live at CPAC in
National Harbor Maryland Doug thanks